in the game of manipulation there's
something called the classic bait and
switch tactic
your victim has something that you want
so you lure your mark in with an
irresistible offer
then you do what's called love bombing
where you overwhelm your victim with
loving words
actions and behaviors to sweep them off
their feet to sink your teeth deeper
into them
you lavish them with gifts favors you
can't stop complimenting them
you give them undivided attention you
get them to commit right here and now
and once their guard is down you start
to extract what's yours
but as soon as you have sucked all the
blood you can from them
as soon as they're no longer of use to
you as soon as your priorities change
that is where the switch comes in the
favor suddenly come to a halt you're no
longer at their beck and call you turner
cole shorter you stop answering their
phone calls
and that is exactly what elon musk and
tesla is experiencing right now with the
chinese government
musk was lured into china china rocks in
my opinion
the energy in china is great people
there are there's like a lot of smart
hard-working people
and they really are they're not entitled
they're not complacent
the red carpet was rolled out for him
his gigafactory was approved and built
in record time
the financing for the factory by chinese
banks was unheard of
half a billion dollars at a cheap rate
where even if tesla defaulted on the
loan the banks wouldn't have any legal
claims on tesla
tesla had full access and support from
the upper echelons of the chinese
government and they were even given
unprecedented support during covert
compared to competitors
it seemed like the perfect geopolitical
bromance i would like to strike an
optimistic note
and say that i'm very confident that the
future in china is going to be great
and china became instrumental in elon's
rise to the richest man in the world
trying to like i think long term will be
our biggest market
both where we make the most number of
vehicles and where we have the most of
our customers
but then the switch happened china
banned some of tesla's cars from
military complexes
public outcry against the safety of
tesla vehicles rose uncensored online
without any credible evidence
making some believe that officials were
quietly supporting or even enabling the
outcry
which brings us to today we're out of
nowhere beijing orders almost every
single tesla sold in the nation to be
recalled
over 285 000 in total to fix a software
safety issue
so it looks like the honeymoon phase
between tesla and china is over
the only question left is why
[Music]
some of the articles you've seen on
screen so far were these bite-sized easy
to read couple paragraph long articles
from today's video sponsor
morning brew and morning brew is free so
you're going to want to stick around for
this morning brew is a daily newsletter
written for gen z and millennials that
makes reading the news actually
enjoyable so you can stay informed and
entertain for free every day of the week
all you have to do is open up their
email in the morning and boom you get a
quick view of the markets you get the
hottest stories from different
categories summed up in just a few
paragraphs and morning brews witty yet
straight to the point writing you get a
quick list of what else is trending
right now
all of which you can consume in just
five minutes and one simple email
which means no more long drawn out news
articles from traditional media that
takes 15 minutes to read
i personally use morningbrew to get a
quick 10 second rundown of the most
interesting things happening in the
world that i should know about and if it
looks interesting i'll go deeper into it
like how tesla scored record profits
even though it's facing supply chain
challenges
quote liked the toilet paper shorts but
at epic scale and quotes in elon musk's
words
so pause the video click the link below
and subscribe to morningbrew so you can
get smarter every morning
it's completely free takes less than 15
seconds to sign up you literally just
type in your email so there's no reason
for you not to subscribe right now with
the link below
[Music]
china is the world's biggest market for
evs in 2020 they were responsible for
buying around 1.2 million evs which is
around 40
of the global total so moving one of the
world's most famous ev
brands into the country seemed like a
good idea at the time after all it's not
just that chinese people wanted evs but
their government actually makes driving
these cars cheaper than buying a normal
gas vehicle
the chinese government offers subsidies
and incentives for people who buy
plug-in hybrids or fully electric cars
some chinese cities even penalize people
who own normal cars like in shanghai
where license plates for cars that use
gas have to be bought at auction for
around fourteen thousand dollars
while place for evs are totally free so
it's not surprising that tesla saw the
chance of eating up the chinese ev
market as a no-brainer
i mean if a giant market wants your
product and even the government is
pushing people to buy it why wouldn't
you enter that market
and tesla entering the chinese market
was good for the chinese government as
well
at the time car sales were slumping in
china and chinese evs just weren't as
good and didn't attract consumers
so they thought that bringing in a
widely recognized brand like tesla would
give their domestic ev manufacturers a
much needed competition
and having the opportunity to steal some
of tesla's intellectual property as they
have a history of doing with foreign
companies was another bonus
before their move into china teslas were
pretty rare in the country
in 2015 they only sold around 3 700
imported cars compared to a local
competitor with almost 10 times as many
sales
adjusting their cars for this new market
took time and they made a lot of
mistakes
like not accounting for the fact that
the wealthy and china usually have show
first and one of fancy back seats
or how their infotainment system would
need to be updated with chinese apps
or how tesla charging ports were
compatible with national standards
even after all these issues were fixed
tesla still faced a major setback in
sales
all their cars were made in the us and
the chinese government subsidies didn't
apply to imported vehicles
this was one of the main reasons that
the move into china seemed like such a
great idea
even after many tesla executives said
the company should be cautious
especially when it came to protecting
intellectual property
despite all these worries when tencent
holdings one of china's largest tech
brands bought a 5
stake in tesla elon musk took it as a
sign to start expanding tesla's presence
in the country
so tesla started looking for cities to
set up shop and must turn to doing what
he does best negotiating the terms and
incentives for building a factory in the
country
one of his biggest asks was that tesla
would have 100 control over their
operations
and that no other company chinese or
international could have a stake
this went way against the traditional
requirement that foreign companies
entering into china had to go into a 50
50 joint venture with a chinese firm
you could blame it on the u.s china
trade war or the fact that china really
needed to rebuild its reputation of
being welcoming to foreign companies
but less than a year after negotiations
started musk got approved for full
control of tesla in the people's
republic
which was again unheard of for a foreign
company especially one from the us
a couple months later tesla and the
shanghai government sealed the deal for
a tesla gigafactory able to produce up
to half a million evs a year
and the good times just kept rolling in
and elon musk seemed to really like the
royal treatment even famously saying i
love china while meeting one of the top
government officials premier league
state bad banks agreed to offer tesla up
to half a billion dollars for
constructing the factory with some great
terms
local officials were placed on site to
process paperwork faster and connecting
the factory to running water only took
four days
insanely fast compared to typical
constructions premier league even went
as far as to offer much permanent
residency in the country and it seemed
like the bromance had blossomed into a
full-blown love affair teslas were made
exempt from the 10
new vehicle tax the first foreign car
brand to get the special treatment and
by december 2019
tesla got yet another 1 billion
financing deal from the bank
and just before the start of 2020 tesla
delivered its first ever chinese
evs and shortly after the factory was
already hitting up to a thousand cars a
week and chinese consumers went crazy
over the cars and the brand
it seemed as though tesla could do no
wrong and the chinese government was
eating from the palm of their hand
for a while tesla's move into china
looked like it could be the company's
greatest success story yet
everything seemed perfect the chinese
government became one of tesla's biggest
marketers
doing everything they could to lure
people into buying evs
more than 120 000 cars were sold in 2020
and china became tesla's second biggest
market after the us
forecasters predicted that by 2022 china
would account for more than 40
of all of tesla's sales and the
predictions got better with the
companies mono y set to outsell their
model 3
but then covet hit everyone thought it
would be the end of tesla production at
least for the time being
but no the elon musk china love affair
blazed on and tesla was treated with the
very best treatment the state had to
offer
buses were provided to bring workers to
the factory dorms were being guarded by
state officials to ensure workers didn't
mingle with the community and they had
plenty of n95 masks while other chinese
businesses struggled to get their hands
on enough to even cover their essential
employees
while other car manufacturers were
struggling to start up their factories
tesla produced a thousand cars in their
first week back
and by march 2020 they broke the record
they set before kovid and increased
their production rate to 3 000 evs a
week
elon musk had become the chinese
president's favorite capitalist which
raises the question
what did china really want out of it at
first it seemed their country had been
transparent about their motives
tesla would be the driving force behind
china's ev revolution and forced many of
the almost 500 local companies building
their own evs to up their game
like in the smartphone industry where
apple's manufacturing in china provides
healthy competition for brands like
huawei and oppo
tesla would trigger the development of
the entire ev supply chain not just
their own
unfortunately for tesla this reality
came true tesla did in fact raise the
bar for local ev manufacturers like neo
and xping their tech was getting better
and their sales had been on the rise
[Music]
all the while as us china relations
spiraled to the lowest point since the
90s
all of a sudden tesla wasn't so useful
to the chinese government anymore their
priorities changed
tesla took the bait and now it was time
for the switch
starting in february 2021 tesla quickly
started running into problems
a video went viral of a staff member
telling a tesla owner a national power
grid overload had damaged her ev
and tesla had to quickly issue an
apology to the state-owned power grid
company
suddenly tesla executives were being
summoned by chinese regulators
to discuss safety issues in their cars
including reports of random acceleration
and battery fires
and right after that meeting tesla bent
the knee putting out an apology that was
on the verge of bootlicking
about how tesla had sincerely accepted
the guidance of government departments
and deeply reflected on shortcomings
later that same month
tesla started giving its pr department
serious attention to rebuild his
reputation
then in march tesla really started
feeling the change in the government's
favor
when some of his cars were banned from
military complexes over fears that they
could be sending their camera data back
to the us government
now in damage control tesla makes yet
another statement that their cameras
aren't a threat and that any data
collected is stored within the country
at the prestigious shanghai auto show a
woman jumped onto one of the tesla
vehicles and claimed that her brakes had
failed causing an
accident pictures and videos of the
protest spread uncensored online even
though there was no compelling evidence
that what she was saying was true
tesla asked the government to use their
censoring powers to stop the spread
which made some people wonder if the
chinese government intentionally wanted
this to spread or was even enabling it
but tesla came out of the cage swinging
saying that it was never their fault and
the woman had been manipulated into
doing what she did
this reaction made them look even worse
and they later had to issue yet another
apology again
and provide data surrounding the
accident all these apologies made for
some really bad publicity and sales
dropped by 50
over just a few weeks then in late april
china dealt yet another blow to the
company
stating that all smart cars would need
to store their data in country
considering that tesla was the only
foreign ev manufacturer it was pretty
easy to see who the statement was
directed towards
[Music]
and by may things just kept getting
worse local governments started
reviewing tesla ownership among their
employees
and then came the last straw
in june after claiming tesla's autopilot
system could be activated automatically
and possibly lead to crashes
beijing ordered pretty much all of
nearly 300 000 tesla cars sold in china
to be recalled and their software
upgraded for free to fix the safety
issue
tesla had to apologize again and this
was one of the most embarrassing
setbacks for tesla thus far and it did
the most damage to tesla's reputation in
the country
it really showed just how far tessa had
fallen out of favor with the chinese
government
tesla served a purpose at the beginning
of their relationship but now they don't
so they've been thrown to the wayside
and the honeymoon is over
another major factor in the china tesla
breakup was the breakdown of the
country's relationship with the us
when tesla first started working with
china the country was still trying to
show that it was willing to work with
the us
now with the u.s outright calling china
a strategic rival and the country's
borders remaining closed
we'll also take on directly the
challenges posed
by our prosperity security and
democratic values by
our most serious competitor china
china showing that it's willing to work
with u.s companies isn't a big priority
anymore
and like many who came before them
tesla's experience in china serves as a
warning sign of the perils of working in
the chinese market
the question is what happens from here
[Music]
tesla is still doing well overall they
made 12 billion in the second quarter of
2021 nearly double what they earned the
year before they hit over a billion
dollars in profit for the first time and
they still have some of their biggest
fans in china with that being said their
overall stock is down nearly 10
in 2021 while gm is up 38 and china's
crackdown on tesla is also part of a
much bigger crackdown happening right
now with tech in general in china
so as that happens as tensions continue
flaring between the us and china and
more and more brands crowd the ev market
it could definitely put a bigger squeeze
on tesla in china i think we need a few
more months of sales data to know for
sure if tesla is in a major slump in the
world's biggest car market or whether
they simply been hitting a few speed
bumps along the way
but as we mentioned this is just another
lesson of how if a government has the
power to give you everything
they also have the power to take it all
away at a moment's notice
as soon as you are no longer useful to
them
so what do you think of tesla's
relationship with china was this super
obvious that this was going to happen
were you surprised
do you understand why elon would want to
go into china in the first place because
after
all if everything goes according to plan
they probably will be the biggest
economy in the world within a few years
so let me know what you guys think in
the comments below
morningbrew our video sponsor you should
check them out with the link below
because it is free and literally all you
have to do is click the link
then you type in your email and you
click enter and that's literally it then
you will get the latest news every
single day into your inbox that you can
consume in less than five minutes that i
and many other people very much enjoy
that will be linked below for you guys
to check out and if you're not aware
supporting the sponsor of a channel is
probably the best way
to support a channel financially and
this one is free too so if you want to
support you can sign up if you're new
here we make video essays every single
week on the most provocative
thought-provoking stuff in the world of
business
geopolitics like this one economics
crime
business money power i'm pretty sure i
just repeated one but yeah you can
subscribe with the red button below for
more videos just like this every single
week for free
if you want behind the scenes stuff then
the life kind of stuff you can follow me
on instagram jaketrend.io and that
should be it for this video thank you so
much for watching you've been awesome
i've been jake as always stay dangerous
out there
and i will see you guys in the next one
[Music]
you